ce 14 décembre marque en france
l'apparition des premiers kits en euros
un vrai succès dévaliser les guichets
des postes pour certains dès la fin de
matinée
les françaises se sont rués sur les
sachets des premiers euros pour
reprendre l'expression d'un laurent
fabius plutôt jovial nous sommes heureux
impatients reportage cyrille devaud
alexandre de laval beurre numério dans
ses cartons martin pradalier conservait
précieusement 200 sachet de rouge en
seulement une heure et demie ils ont
tous été l'idée c'était la vraie folie
ce matin tout le monde en voulait pour
leurs enfants leurs petits-enfants pour
donner en cadeau
voilà on a été dévalisée owendo dans le
bureau de tabac d'à côté ce sont 500
sachez qu'ils ont disparu en à peine
deux heures on pensait pouvoir
satisfaire davantage de clients mais le
problème c'est que tout le monde n'a pas
joué le jeu
amis lesquels la poste par exemple qui
est là aujourd'hui
la poste la voici après une matinée de
grève les portes ont été ouvertes cet
après-midi résultats euro rationnée et
embouteillages monstres au guichet dès
qu'on a ouvert en live cette cup
voilà donc combien la junte 45 minutes
malgré la grève et la cohue la poste a
distribué presque la moitié de ses 9
millions de sachets sont en place mais
demain je veux dire c'est la même
cochonneries que les pièces espagnoles
comme je suis espagnol je suis habitué
les banques ont été les plus scrupuleuse
elles se sont tenues à la règle pas plus
d'un sachet par personne quitte à faire
des mécontents
on voyait donc dès cet après-midi les
plus malins à viviez devisscher en débit
sabah pour chanter le quitte ou double
face et mon deuxième akif parce que j'ai
été à l'avant car ils n'ont pas donné un
deuxième jour du quartier bastille
matran si j'ai deux heures profile et sa
copine nuit et les premiers sachets
vendu à cette cliente parisienne l'euro
est donc devenu star en moins d'une
journée